in case you have not noticed President
Biden spent most of the week resting and
recovering after a quick trip to South
Carolina and Texas on Monday but today
he's back in Action good for Joe after
finally mustering the energy to meet
with voters in Pennsylvania this time
his Focus was on once again we thought
it was dead he's bringing back bomic now
of course he didn't have much to say
because there's very little good news on
the economy to share in fact the most
recent inflation report was even worse
than expected now we'll bring you the
low light straight ahead but now we turn
to the president's adult son uh zero
experience Hunter who is once again
asking for special treatment after
allegedly now failing to pay taxes on
what is millions of dollars in income
money he purportedly acquired by selling
access to the federal government through
the Biden brand uh we need Washington
help as the barisma executive said
Hunter is now determined to waste even
more time and resources at the taxpayers
expense now first he refused to comply
with a legally binding Congressional
subpoena now you might remember
president Trump's uh children they
complied with multiple subpoenas from
house Democrats not Hunter he believes I
guess he deserves special treatment and
then of course the big stunt Hunter
showing up at his own contempt hearing
with his own camera crew in tow and the
president's son apparently trying to
make a clown show out of What was a
serious official proceeding to film
content for his upcoming documentary and
the hopes I guess of making even more
money but now that the president's
entitled son is facing a real
possibility of contempt of congress
charges well Hunter wants a doover and
is now demanding that the house issue a
brand new subpoena that he can accept
and by the way Hunter's attorneys even
suggested possible terms for the new
subpoena Hunter is playing games with
the people's house in order to drag this
out as long as possible he has had no
respect for this ongoing investigation
he's had no respect for the rule of law
and neither has his father the big guy
Joe now you would think during an
election year the bidens might want to
quickly clear their good name if they
have one if they truly have done nothing
wrong and have nothing to hide they
would want to answer questions from
members of Congress well that wouldn't
be a problem would it if he didn't do
anything wrong if his father didn't
leverage a billion dollars taxpayer
dollars to get a prosecutor fired so
that his son who admits he had no
experience in energy or Ukraine was
being paid Millions uh at a time when he
was addicted to drugs but given the
constant lies the constant obstruction
from both Joe and Hunter it is clear
that a contempt of congress charge is
the least of their worries there is
certainly no guarantee that Hunter will
ever comply with the house ofena anyway
and today I think that law professor
Jonathan Turley nailed it and he put out
a piece of advice to Republican law
lawmakers this is what he said the
response to Hunter by the house should
be short and should be simple toying
with Congress may have had recreational
and political appeal but it also has
legal costs Hunter may be the
president's son but he does not get a
mulligan on contempt in a joint
statement house chairman comr and
Judiciary Committee chairman Jordan said
they will allow Hunter to comply with
the original subpoena but in the
meantime the house will proceed with
their contempt resolution now of course
for most Americans there are no legal
Mulligans if you try to defraud the
federal government for years and not pay
your taxes uh guess what you don't get a
doover when you get caught if you lie on
a gun application and then oh your gun
ends up in a trash can near a school
well you're not going to get sympathy
from any federal prosecutor now if your
name is Paul manaport and you fail to
register under Pharaoh laws while the
Washington field office of the FBI we
now know they're not going to look the
other way so why should it be any
different for Hunter Biden now why does
he deserve special treatment why has he
been given so much uh special treatment
why did David Weiss allow the statute of
limitations to expire on so many serious
tax violations they just happened to
coincide with the barisma earning years
why did doj attempt to sweep all of
Hunter Biden's crimes under the rug
remember Weiss originally his plan a was
not to charge Hunter and then of course
the whistleblowers came out and he had
no choice so they went to plan B that
was a sweetheart deal well that got
blown up by a judge in Delaware that
actually had the uh wherewithal to read
the agreement and ask the defense team
have you ever seen an agreement like
this before uh know your honor then why
are you handing this to me and that is
now resulted in a special counsel but
it's still the same guy that didn't want
to charge hunter in the first place the
Federal Government is so deeply biased
and corrupt it should make every
American sick this is what we talk about
when we talk about whether or not the
doj has been weaponized and politicized
and the FBI weaponized and politicized
as Hunter Biden now faces felony charges
for skipping out on over a million
dollars in taxes now his father bragged
about making Americans pay their fair
share quote unquote as of today the IRS
has collected over 500 million in unpaid
taxes from 1,600 millionaires using
resources for my inflation reduction act
well this is about the super wealthy
needing to pay what they owe uh and what
the existing tax code calls for just
like hardworking Americans do is he
going to give that lecture to his son
Hunter because they made Millions he had
no experience he was addicted to drugs
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else